P's Cubs sharpen their survival
skills relishing Freedom while their
mother hunts away from
[Music]
home but Freedom has its
risks
baboons merciless
Killers the boy races for
cover his sister takes a different route
[Music]
not a good
move baboons climb trees
too you're on your
own
PFO is well beyond
[Music]
earshot forced by the drought to travel
further and further in search of food
for her
Cubs
another Hunter has eaten
[Music]
well it's only skin and
bone
anxious not to be away too
long peo Begins the long journey
[Music]
home she senses
danger her
[Music]
daughter
trapped the Cub can only climb
[Music]
higher P's mind races
outnumbered
outmaneuvered out of
luck
[Music]
he
the baboons are finally done with the
Cub is she injured is she even
alive The Savage Kingdom deserves its
name
but today is an
[Music]
exception scared but
unscathed nothing A Mother's Love cannot
[Music]
Soo but there's still no sign of her
son
silence
it's
[Music]
him until the rains come and bring prey
closer your Cubs will never be safe
[Music]
per
Time Heals all
[Music]
wounds as the land turns to dust
T and her sister teach the teenagers to
hunt with a special respect for what a
warthog can
do Rebels no more the boys study the
sisters every
move
[Music]
stealth Pati
the
attack
[Music]
a master class in the art of
hunting the kill quells their pangs of
[Music]
hunger but one little pig won't feed a
hungry
[Music]
Pride especially if it's
stolen
[Music]
hyena
T used to face these thieves
[Applause]
[Music]
alone but not this
time
whatever the boys lack in hunting
skills they make up fall in raw
power the team me show their loyalty to
Tata and the
[Music]
pride now boys prove you can
hunt
Wham leads her pack North away from the
hyena and the endless
drought and into the waterfill flood
[Music]
Plains here the pack bathes in
success
[Music]
wame knows her pups are
hungry and this is unfamiliar
territory time to test the
waters
wh May leads the
[Music]
charge the water it's too
deep marshes are exactly where the swamp
Antelope evolved to
[Music]
survive poor
W out of your
depth and now you have
company
[Music]
Lions punish
trespasses wame has laid her pack
straight into Lion
Country
[Music]
the party is
over better by far to face the
drought than live in a Den of
Lions
[Music]
but sebie has no interest in chasing
pesky
dogs she only wants to be with her
[Music]
sister and their five
Cubs after Escaping The Three
Brothers they too are
[Music]
refugees sebbe can't afford to relax for
long
[Music]
she has land to
conquer and her sister to help
her the huntresses are new of this
flooded
Fortress
but together they lay claim to Mambo's
duwel in the
crowd it's hard to be silent in a world
of
water
but sebie and her sister are in perfect
[Music]
snc watch those tusks
sebie
even the greatest Empires begin with a
single
[Music]
step
the Cubs can't wait to fill their
bellies and this meal is
special it's their first taste of
meat on they couldn't be more
[Music]
delicious for sebbi it's proof that
joining her sister was the right thing
to
[Music]
do and nothing can stop them from ruling
this
[Music]
land
in the infernal heat of the South Tata
also makes a
[Music]
kill but she has much bigger mouths to
feed and many more of
them the teenagers now
share but there's still not enough to go
round tter Spurs the boys into
[Music]
action can they turn what they learned
into
lunch as Tata leads
the boys take their
[Music]
positions it's crucial they stay
hidden and do exactly as T
taught
timing is
everything they're too hasty
the boys must curb their
enthusiasm but they are starting to show
promise T's heart
sores her Pride pulling together at
last
[Music]
p is in
luck a veret
monkey
in the drought ridden
South it's not half
bad once again the search for prey takes
her far from
home and she longs to get back to her
Cubs
having stashed her
kill peo is anxious to check they are
well the Cubs are slow to
appear
[Music]
but better safe than
sorry PFO can breathe
easy her Cubs can't live on Love Alone
they need
[Music]
food The Feisty little girl is first to
eat and boldly refuses to share with her
[Music]
mother
once she's had her fill it's her
brother's
[Music]
turn peo settles for the
scraps
and even these she lets her son steal
[Music]
back p is willing to sacrifice
anything for the good of her precious
Cubs but will the Reigns come and bring
her a proper meal before she gets too
weak to
[Music]
hunt in the flooded
North sebe and her sister stake their
claim
the perfect
team
the abundance of food means their cubs
are growing
fast for sebbe forced to give up her
family once
before it's a second chance at
[Music]
happiness
suddenly that chance looks
Fragile seb's Heart
pounds terrified he could kill her
Cubs or force her to give up her family
once
more
Over My Dead
Body a lone
male capable of
anything but as he draws
near sebbi recognizes him
it's the father of her
Cubs SE remains
wary he's hardly been the model of
reliability
she leaves her sister to
babysit and greets the weary
[Music]
traveler perhaps he's
changed
he seems calmer
now more
[Music]
mature more
Regal
she'll let him stay but she doesn't have
time to flirt all
day she has an Empire to
build
[Music]
wame leads the pack away from se's water
soak
land and back to the infernal
drought a land of
famine and
[Music]
scavengers but at least a land wh
understands with her pups hungry and the
hyena nowhere to be
seen
she leads a
[Music]
hunt through the Searing
heat the dogs run mile after
mile finally they can run no
more
but a true leader never
sleeps the time for rest is
[Music]
over it's time now for
dinner
back on firm ground wh's dogs run freely
once
[Music]
more
a feast at
[Music]
last
it was only a matter of time before
their Nemesis turned
up
hyena never knowingly late to a
party body
snatches and pup
Killers
hyena Robbers from
hell wame and the pack fled North to
escape
them this time wame is not going
anywhere the pack rallies behind
[Music]
her the dogs give everything they
have even W's pups join The
Fray big enough to hold their own at
last a credit to their incredible
mother after everything W's leadership
is finally set in
stone never to be challenged
[Music]
again
rain finally here to quench the land's
bitter
[Music]
thirst
bringing Solace to
[Music]
all
no one welcomes the change of season
more than
peo all she wants is to feed her tiny C
s thankfully her Forest Now teams with
prey of the easiest
[Music]
kind no time for Mercy
peo you have your CBS to
feed
sh that proper meal at
last enough for all the
[Music]
family you just have to get it to them
PUO that's
[Music]
all PUO B Bly goes where no hyena can
follow but what goes
up will eventually come
down where hell's teeth are
waiting
peo clings to her Cub's
meal she knows hyena have little
patience just hold out
peo
[Music]
free at
last this time there's more than enough
to go go
round so even you peo get a share of the
[Music]
feast having brought her family through
the toughest of drugs and the most
dangerous period of their
lives PFO can now enjoy a time of
Plenty with her two precious
[Music]
Cubs
Tata is
ready lured by the promise of
water the heavy weights
arrive enormous beasts with enormous
thirst and enormous hor
horns Tata can't take them on
alone she won't have
to the teens are primed and
[Music]
ready
time to see what the boys can
do under tata's Guidance the teens
isolate a pair of Buffalo
female and calf
perfect
the teacher creates a
distraction while her students go in for
the mother of all
prices
a banquet for a hungry
Pride the teens finally show their true
worth all thanks to
Tata she transformed broken Pride into a
mighty
[Music]
Dynasty a dynasty to match that of the a
inspiring
[Music]
SE each now Reigns over their own
Promised
Land TARTA Queen of the
South SE Que Queen of the
North together they rule the mighty
Savage
[Music]
Kingdom